the worst drug disaster in history would
spread through more than 46 countries
and produce up to 20 000 badly deformed
babies worldwide
[Music]
but historians today single out one
birth in 1961 that changed the course of
history
in hamburg germany linda schulte hillen
aged 23 gave birth to her first child
her husband wasn't with her at the time
and it was quiet there
and then
i
lay back and was relaxed and some i mean
somebody whispered into my ear is your
husband not all right
and i was here wide awake and i said
what what's go what has happened to my
baby is anything wrong
yeah she said just
let's say um
without any emotion
um
yeah he's just got short arms and i
like a child would have asked possibly i
said
and aren't they growing anymore and she
said this can't grow this will be like
it is now
and then i felt like i was beaten to
death
a doctor gave the first time mother some
friendly advice just get another child
like forget about him you know
throw him away forget about him
shortly afterwards linda's husband
arrived and gave her some bad news he'd
been keeping from her six weeks earlier
his sister had given birth to a baby
with similar deformities it looks alike
like our child there must be something
that is
the same origin the same difficulty the
same problem in the background and we'll
find it and we'll search and we won't
stop until we've found
[Music]
the epidemic of deformed babies began
five and a half years earlier on
christmas day 1956 with the birth of the
first victim
[Music]
in the small town of achen germany a
mother had taken a new drug called
thalidomide being developed by a local
drug company kami grunenthal her husband
like other grunenthal employees had
taken home a sample which he gave to his
pregnant wife
the baby would be the first of six
solider my babies possibly more born to
grinenthal workers in the years ahead
but the company ignored the early
warning signals in their midst none of
that spurred green entitled to any
action gruntile didn't
investigate didn't talk to the mum
didn't go to the hospital didn't look at
the medical records didn't contact
experts
there were multiple opportunities for
granted to cut the whole disaster short
none of them were taken
nine months after the first deformed
baby was born brunenthal launched the
linobide onto the german market under
the brand name contagon
grinenthal's aggressive sales force
whose motto was succeed at any cost
continued to promote the drug
contagon they claimed was a safe
sedative especially for pregnant women
suffering from morning sickness
sales zoomed and thalidomide became the
second best-selling drug next to aspirin
but linda schulte hillen and her husband
carl herrmann were determined to find
out what caused their son's short arms
months later they were no closer to
finding an answer i know my husband had
times when he said
we won't make it
i think we've to give up
and i said and we are not giving up
her husband soon contacted a professor
of obstetrics dr viduken lens who had
received a few reports of deformed
babies
my father and professor lenz they
traveled germany in their old volkswagen
and they went from one small village to
another
and
asked are there any children with short
legs or short arms born and those kids
were hidden away at that time in the
small villages
and he asked in restaurants and bars and
at the local police office and everybody
said no not in our town and then he
showed a picture of me
and said this is my boy and can i please
repeat my question and then they said
well at the end of the road
there has been a very sad incident and
then he went there and drink the dawn
show first thing he did was showing the
picture of me and said this is my son do
you also have have a kid like this
the people burst in tears and
and children telling my children were
well pulled to the day of light
literally
[Music]
in england thalidomide was being sold
under the brand name distaval by the
country's largest liquor manufacturer
the distillers company
as in germany distillers had received
reports of deformed babies but had been
assured by grinenthal that the drug was
completely safe
louise mason was one of 530 thalidomide
babies born in england over a six and a
half year period
louise only learned about the
circumstances of her birth by reading
her father's best-selling autobiography
i hadn't got any arms and i hadn't got
any legs
and my dad said
it was like little flower buds
and
you know from my arms and from my legs
my dad had a look at me
and um
he said my god you're not going to let
this
baby live
and they said yes
my mum was only 21
and she was advised by doctors
to um
put me away
and
concentrate on having
another family
after 11 days in hospital her parents
took louise to an institution for
handicapped children
where she would spend the next 18 years
of her life
but louise was fortunate her father had
not asked another doctor to end her life
it is unquestionable
that midwives and doctors
were killing
disabled children
in the hospitals in the delivery rooms
on a large scale
in britain
in germany
and if they're probably everywhere else
in liege belgium the mother of an
armless baby decided her daughter's
future was hopeless
this was the final day of the
thalidomide trial the baby's mother and
four accomplices were charged with the
murder of the child born without arms
at last the jury retired to consider
their verdict
not guilty all five acquitted what
relief and what a reception they got
[Music]
in canada another armless baby was
spared by a poor ukrainian family in
rural saskatchewan
years later alvin law learned how
horrified his natural parents were when
he was born ultimately it was
the
paternal grandmother who didn't want to
have anything to do with this she said
you're not going to bring that devil
baby home with you he's
he's
deformed because of a curse
the armless baby wasn't taken home after
doctors warned he would never lead a
normal life
but after six weeks an elderly couple
jack and hilda law who had already
raised their own children volunteered as
foster parents and got their first look
at alvin i took one look and i thought
no wonder nobody wanted that
and the next time i went to see him of
course they had him bathed and dressed
and he didn't look too bad at all
well i wasn't in favor of taking him
talk away
we'd raised our family and that was it
but
it was a baby with nobody wanted him so
what he can do
turned out okay
my life story
shifted
the moment that sophie
and peter my birth father gave me up
that that that is a profound chapter
shift in my life
because i went to live with the laws
my life became this life
[Music]
[Applause]
in cincinnati ohio a deeply religious
roman catholic couple with six children
were expecting another normal birth my
mother's story is that when i was born
they were not at all prepared
the doctor said joy
your baby doesn't have any legs
so she says that she took the baby me
and she said well eileen is my four-leaf
clover
i have a sibling who told me that my
father cried
and that when he came home he handed me
to my siblings and everyone got very
upset
and they said
take it away
um
someone ripped off the blankets and said
that's not a baby or something to that
effect that's not our sister
um
that was what i was told
as a young child um
painful
eileen cronin was one of several
thalidomide babies born in cincinnati
where an american drug company
richardson merrill had their
headquarters
like the german drug company merrill
promoted the drug as completely safe
even during pregnancy
like grunenthal merrill had no evidence
to back this up
merrill applied to the federal drug
administration in 1960 for approval to
bring thalidomide onto the american
market
and was allowed to conduct clinical
trials on patients across the country
now it wasn't a clinical trial at all
what it was was a marketing campaign
trumped up to look like a clinical trial
michael magazanik is an australian
lawyer and former investigative reporter
who spent years researching the
thalidomide disaster
what merrell wanted to do was to
familiarize doctors with their drug so
that once they got approval they would
have doctors all ready to go thrilled
with the drug ready to prescribe it like
crazy
during this time richardson merrill
handed out two and a half million
thalidomide pills to thousands of
doctors in the united states and canada
in winnipeg dr claude murphy was one of
those doctors we received it in
quantities like a thousand pills a
doctor was given free
to pass out to his patients there was
tremendous pressure on all over the
world to get this wonderful new
drug on the market and the
companies that were producing it
even after the
questions about its safety kept right on
pushing it
dr murphy had good reason to be
concerned about the emerging thalidomide
disaster as he awaited the birth of his
fourth child his wife peggy had been
prescribed thalidomide by another doctor
i'd warned the nurses at the hospital we
could be in for trouble and we wheeled
it into the delivery room and i went
into the doctor's
dressing room
i turned look through the window and i
saw the nurse looking with horror at the
at the stretcher you know and realized
there was something wrong so i
burst into the room and he he'd kill a
breach you see because of his lack of
legs of a small bum and his large head
there he was stuck with on the stretcher
with
just his bottom
so the nurse got me a pair of forceps
and i
slipped the forceps
over his after-coming head and delivered
him
and
if i hadn't been there
he never would have made it
so as soon as he was born
he started
screaming
no hesitation at all he's there
never stopped screaming since
thanks
i'd have to say i was pretty devastated
by the whole thing i'd never dealt with
anybody who had
like physical deficiencies before and
then i had to
to
break the news to the other kids and did
that the next day or so
it was
surprising
awesome
well they said
um dad you got to bring that baby home
[Music]
thalidomide was now being sold in close
to 50 countries worldwide in 1961 in
australia dr william mcbride delivered
three thalidomide babies in a few months
he alerted distillers the british
distributor thalinamite but they claimed
they never received his warnings and
pregnant mothers like wendy rowe
continued to take thalidomide for
morning sickness
but when her daughter lynette was born
wendy immediately knew something was
wrong
when she was born there was just deadly
silence in the in the room
and i just knew that something
must be wrong and
nobody said a word it was just
loud silence
and
anyway finally they said to me that
there was a problem and
that lynn had no arms and legs and
you know and they gave it to me and she
she doesn't look very different to what
she does now she had sticky up hair and
the cutest little face
and um
but i yeah it's just like
well it was like a nightmare i suppose
you know
but then i you know when you you looked
at her and thought well you
you've got to love it you can't you know
you can't do anything about it but they
said we think she's got some brain
damage but we don't know what extent and
i just looked at her and i thought
there's this little thing
no arms and legs and if she's got brain
damage as well what hope has she got
they told me that i should put her in a
home that she would be dead in six
months
we left her there for a week while we
went away
just to get our head around it all and
then came back to pick her up and that
was really hard going back to the
hospital to pick her up
[Music]
in germany gruningthal's advertising
campaign was paying huge dividends the
company's owner and executives were
making fortunes overnight especially
heinrich mukhtar grenanthal's research
director
during the war mukhtar served as a nazi
doctor developing vaccines which were
tested on jewish prisoners in the
buchenwald concentration camp many of
whom died
after the war mukhtar joined gruningthal
nine years later he invented thalidomide
and received a bonus for every
thalidomide pill sold worldwide the drug
was such a success for grin and powell
that they started making money hand over
fist
and heinrich mukhter who was on a
percentage of profits
moved from being modestly affluent
to having so much money pouring in he
could have bought himself a new mercedes
every month by 1961 really he's making
20 times his salary
in
turnover percentage so he's getting this
massive massive bonus he's become a
ludicrously rich man on the back of
thalidomide
what would a man like that with a
history of wartime experimentation
strong personality a massive income
riding on the sales of thalidomide what
would one expect that he would do when
confronted with reports of nerve damage
and other side effects and it is not
surprising to me that there was not a
rush at green and tail to investigate to
get to the bottom of it to put warnings
on the drug to withdraw to take all
sorts of precautions they did none of
that they just focused on selling more
of the drug
in germany where the pills sold at a
rate of 15 million a month 5 000
children have been born deformed from
stohlberg germany morley safer reports
in november of 1961 just 300 miles from
here in hamburg dr vitikun lentz the
director of human genetics at the
university of hamburg
found an astounding increase in the
number of deformed babies
he deduced that contra gan or
thalidomide was the cause
it was clearly going to take something
or someone extraordinary to force
grunden tail to withdraw the drug and
that didn't happen until lans contacted
them
he spoke to heinrich mukhter and said i
have these very strong suspicions i have
14 cases of birth malformations where i
think it could only be thalidomide i
think you ought to withdraw the drug
muktar wouldn't withdraw it
instead grunenthal's response to lens
was to send out reassuring letters to
german doctors grunentale sent out 66
000 letters to german doctors declaring
their drug was safe
66 000 letters to german doctors
i mean you know
it's that was a period where they'd been
told that their drug was likely
responsible for an epidemic of
malformations and deaths
and they're telling doctors their drug
is safe and it really wasn't until the
press got hold of it
and they knew it was going to go public
that they finally backed off and agreed
on november 28 1961 a day after the
thalidomide scandal made headlines in
west germany grinenthal announced it was
withdrawing the drug from the market
even if as late as the spring of 1961
they had taken the drug off the market
then
they would have spared half the babies
nico von glazzo's disabilities weren't
so severe but as a young child nico had
trouble adjusting to his short arms
they finally
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in england louise mason didn't see her
parents and three siblings for months at
a time
i was left alone most the time my
parents had other children
there's no way that they could leave
them with my nan
because my grandpa was ill
so they just stopped coming
i went home three weeks a year
um for a week
one week in the summer one week
christmas on my weekend easter
every holiday was like
getting to know your brothers and
sisters again
we had a lot of fun when i was a kid we
had a lot of fun i had a very good
childhood
i mean clearly when god made me he
didn't have somebody making handstands
on his mind
so
the handicap came annoying from time to
time even as a child he was completely
free
he was completely fearless
for him it was natural
i don't see myself as
as disabled
let's put it this way i have short arms
and this can come very annoying from
time to time
but i'm not disabled to that i feel
inferior or that i think i cannot do
certain things
in yorkton saskatchewan alvin law's
parents decided the best way to get
their armless son to cope with life was
to turn his toes into fingers
for hours alvin was given manual task to
perform with his feet
now granted having no arms isn't exactly
a rather simple disability it's a very
complicated disability
and i'd be lying if i didn't say it was
a lot of work
a lot of work a lot of time spent by
myself being very lonely being very
afraid and very frustrated
but i think it was the character that
was built
by my parents especially by my parents
that allowed me to not really think that
i was all that different
it's not an easy thing to get dressed
but
again it goes back to the basic theory
of my life and that is do i have someone
look after me or do i look after
myself but more than anything i think
it's a mindset you know that okay
there's a lot of people in our world
that have way bigger problems than i
have so that i have to spend a little
extra effort putting my clothes on
so what
the moment i started using my toes and
my feet and my legs
was the same moment i ceased to have a
disability
in the united states there would have
been thousands of thalidomide babies
like alvin law except for the actions of
one woman dr francis kelsey a
canadian-born doctor and pharmacologist
had just joined the federal drug
administration when she received an
application to bring thalidomide onto
the american market
here was a drug that
looked like it should be no problem but
at the same time there was just a
feeling that
there was something in the data or the
absence of data that
was a cause of concern
the application came from richardson
merrill one of america's oldest drug
companies known years ago for its
best-selling product vix cough drops i
mean kelsey was extraordinarily
determined brave tough resilient and she
kept knocking back meryl's application
she kept telling them that there was not
the testing to back their application
that it was substandard they never
managed to persuade her their drug was
safe and fit for sale merrell poured on
the pressure they contacted the fda 50
times they went behind her back to her
superiors they complained about her in
writing they threatened libel
proceedings they pushed and pushed and
pushed and she was resolute she was
unbelievably tough
i know that we're all most indebted to
dr kelsey the relationship
the hopes that all of us have for our
children in august 1962 president john f
kennedy awarded the highest civilian
honor an american can receive to dr
francis kelsey so kelsey really saved
the united states from a german-style
flolidamide epidemic i mean merrell was
ready to go merrill had tons of the drug
in the united states it had already
spread two and a half million pills
around around the country to doctors
it had a sales force schooled in the
multiple wonders of flutimide and all
the fake inflated claims for its
um usefulness and its safety and if
kelsey had given them the green light
the united states would have been
flooded with the drug and there would
have been a birth malformation epidemic
in that country to rival that in germany
while dr kelsey said i need to know more
i want to have more i demand to have
more the canadian government simply
approved it
and i believe that was below the
standard of what should have been
expected from an industrialized
first world
country like
very civilized canada thalidomide
continued to be sold in canada for four
months after it was withdrawn from the
german market the food and drug
directorate in ottawa issued no warnings
to the public while the drug remained on
pharmacy shelves the canadian government
and its food and drug directorate could
have done something four months earlier
and there are about 30 canadians
whose mothers took the drug
after the whistle had been blown in
germany and after the canadian drug
companies knew that the drug was
dangerous but kept selling it
i come home from the playground one day
my mom says honey good news you're going
to get arms dear i mean you just
remember a day like that right i thought
we were going shopping you know arms or
us i don't know
but i was very confused they they had
hooks and they were made of metal and
plastic and wood i mean i couldn't take
off my shoes i wasn't allowed to use my
feet can you imagine how weird that was
so this became an interesting life
half of my life was being alvin law the
kid with no arms the other half of my
life was this terrible victim of
thalidomide
i lost my sense of who i was
right stick these arms on me i'm not
alvin law anymore
you know alvin law doesn't have any arms
artificial or not
and why why would i need them
i mean there was no good reason not one
good reason
to use them
for years i told them hey these aren't
doing me any good
and it was like shut up
that was how blunt it was
you know we know what we're doing
you don't
[Music]
most fellow dividers don't use
artificial limbs today but eileen cronin
is an exception she wears artificial
legs every day to get around
i was born with
both
legs missing from the knees down
according to my mother i did adapt to
the legs pretty quickly
if you have
you know artificial legs a lot of things
go wrong
you've got to go around conducting your
life
and yet you know you've got a skin
infection and you've got to put your leg
on what are you going to do
me i put the leg on i go that's not
always the best thing to do
but um
that's what i do
in australia artificial limbs proved to
be useless and even dangerous for
lynette rowe these legs
were
designed for lynn to walk in
but
though
terribly dangerous because every step
she took she had to rock from side to
side the least little thing on the path
she would just fall over
straight down
lynette required the full-time care of
her devoted parents
for years her mother's nightly routine
was always the same good morning
and you know getting up in the night and
turning her and giving her a pan and
it's a sort of it's a constant thing
that um
i talk to some young mothers sometimes
and they say oh i've had to get up the
night i said i've been doing that for 52
years
the rows are an extraordinary family
and when i went out there for the first
time to meet um
to meet the family
i found it profoundly moving i mean they
were you know lynn was 47 or 48 years
old by that time
her parents had cared for her as her
primary carers for that entire period
lynn is catastrophically injured
she has a remarkable spirit but she's
catastrophically physically injured and
their parents it's to find her parents
lives
have you had enough thank you you're
sure
okay
[Music]
in march 1967 the owner and eight
executives of grunenthal the german drug
company were charged with criminal
negligence premeditated bodily harm and
manslaughter
among the defendants was heinrich
mukhter the nazi doctor who made a
fortune inventing thalidomide
one german historian has looked
at a short list of grunenthal staff from
the early 60s and he said it's
absolutely astonishing that a small
company should have such a concentration
of convicted war criminals
on its staff
unusual even by the standards of
post-war germany
another top grenanthal executive was
otto ambrose a nazi war criminal known
as the devil's chemist ambrose was
convicted of war crimes he committed at
auschwitz for which he served four years
in prison
but after the war the chemist found no
shortage of employers including dow
chemical j peter grace and the u.s
army's chemical corps before he became
chairman of gruningthal's board of
directors in 1971. so in the 1970s
grunertall had as the chair of its board
a man convicted of mass murder and
slavery at auschwitz it sounds crazy
when you say it out loud i mean a mass
murderer
as the chair of their board
the man who hired nazi war criminals
like ambrose and mukter was grinenthal
owner hermann wurtz
verts was a member of the local nazi
party in his hometown before the second
world war a service for which he was
handsomely rewarded by adolf hitler the
viet's family companies
had actually thrived during the war
years because they'd had a contract from
the german army to supply soap and
detergents
they had been supplied with slave
workers
they had been
basically handed
two companies
on a plate that were both either jewish
owned or jewish controlled
joseph noeberger was the personal lawyer
for gruningthal's owner herrmann verts
but in december 1966 noyberger resigned
suddenly and became justice minister in
the province where the trial was being
held granite house chief defense lawyer
ended up with the government
responsibility for overseeing the
conduct of the trial
that kind of stinks
and one german observer of the day said
this makes us look worse than a banana
republic
away from the trial a secret deal was
worked out between gruningthal's owner
herrmann verts and the provincial
government the secret deal was only
revealed when the trial was dramatically
stopped after two and a half years
under the deal volumes of the
prosecution's evidence would be sealed
from public view
in return for having all the serious
criminal charges against its owner and
executives dropped the company agreed to
pay the victims lifetime pensions
ranging from thirty to a hundred and
forty dollars a month as well as small
one-time payments but in order to
collect the money thalidomiders had to
agree not to launch any further suits
against gruningthal so taken as a whole
the trial was a glorious if unlikely
triumph for grin and tale grunentale
really escaped from the disaster
relatively lightly given the scale and
the scope of the tragedy
[Music]
while canada loudly celebrated its 100th
birthday in 1967
the thalidomide families suffered in
silence a few parents had committed
suicide others became alcoholics and
some were having severe psychiatric
problems
[Music]
the thalidomide children were now school
age but the question that plagued
medical and educational authorities was
what type of school should they enter
some experts recommended schools for the
handicapped while others advised the
regular education system in yorkton
saskatchewan alvin law's parents had run
into opposition from the local grade
school when they tried to enroll him
school says wait he's got no arms he
can't go to this school we don't have
such a thing as integration mom and dad
are going what's integration he's a kid
he needs to go to school he needs to
learn he needs to be educated he can
write he can read what else do you need
the school finally agreed to take alvin
but soon afterwards he ran into a
reaction his teachers expected and
feared i came home and i was very upset
because somebody had called me crippled
and i'd never heard that word before it
was never used in this house
and it was never used in this
neighborhood but i go to school and
there was new kids someone called me
crippled so i had to run home and i was
a little freaked out you know i'm
calming me down and that's when i first
remember hearing those words that some
people are born with black hair and some
people are born with blond hair and you
were born without arms
compared to alvin moni eisenberg's
disabilities were relatively small she
was born with a short arm but
nevertheless her mother was determined
to hide it from public view when she was
a child
only years later did moani understand
why
um
couldn't forget that the first victims
adolf hitler and the nazis rounded up
for extermination were disabled children
she had lived near hadamar hospital one
of the extermination sites
[Music]
um
there was the hospitals where
they were taking
these disabled people
to to be murdered
that were really the test beds for the
holocaust it was it was in a hospital
that the first
gas chambers were being used for bulk
killing of people
um
the medical staff of these places were
very enthusiastic supporters and
i've seen a report from hadamard
hospital where
the the chief of this program organised
a party for all the staff when they had
killed their 10 000th victim
in england 197 families of thalidomide
children were suing distillers the
british company which had distributed
the drug distillers made a ridiculously
low offer of compensation and warned
that the money would be paid out only if
all parents agree to the lifetime deal
five families refused the offer they
were led by david mason a wealthy london
art dealer and father of louise now i
came under tremendous pressure i
received threats on my life
i had a police guard for a period of
time i had anonymous phone calls i had
anonymous letters i had
you know threats from parents
her father's well-publicized opposition
to the compensation created problems for
louise at her care institution
up until then i was like one of the
crowd but after that
i was picked on
and that's when i felt like
i was
alone in amongst the crowd louise
escaped the hostility of her classmates
when her father took her out to
participate in publicity events for his
campaign
i was
used as a as a poster girl
not only because i was his daughter but
because i had
the extremes
of the disability
and visually i had
great impact
david mason's campaign succeeded in
increasing by six times the drug
company's original offer to the parents
i did pay a heavy price personally
but
if i hadn't paid that price
the cylinder midas wouldn't have got the
compensation when they got the
confrontation
so i think it was worth it
[Music]
the littermiters were becoming teenagers
and in winnipeg paul murphy was having a
difficult adolescence
he went to high school with other kids
and of course he did have problems
because he was rejected he did make a
few friends but
uh not very many
i think everybody's running into those
kind of problems but
he or just being told no
i don't want to
go with you because of
your situation
not fun not a nice thing to have happen
nobody likes to have that kind of
rejection thrown at them
but there's some very frustrating times
and and whoever says they've never felt
almost self-destructive
and not want you know jesus would be a
hell of a lot easier
if i wasn't
and i've been to those low points
luckily enough i was able to pull myself
back out
[Music]
alvin law thrived in school and by the
time he was a teenager he seemed to fit
right in
as far as the whole scene of school has
been i think that's the most important
part is being accepted by people if
you're not accepted
it won't be
worth anything
it was about acceptance totally and it
was about asking two or three girls out
on dates to which i heard are you
kidding
i wanted to date just like any 16 year
old
but i didn't have that good fortune
and of course i used to blame it on the
girls
and maybe it was partly them but i know
it was mostly me
i thought that i was going to have to be
a nun
i didn't think that i was going to go on
dates i didn't know what was going to
happen and that that's not how it
happened i i had a great
high school run i mean you know i had a
lot of fun i had a lot of friends i had
too much fun
if you're like me and my friends you
drive around and you look for pools and
you go skinny dipping and that's what we
did for entertainment
i never had a problem with girls
i could always get very nice girls
beautiful girls intelligent girls
but i couldn't get the stupid blonde one
and i wanted the stupid blonde one for a
one night stand
but that i never achieved
she was wearing glasses and i didn't
notice
[Laughter]
i found my
now wife when she was 16
and
maybe you call it a lack of opportunity
but i'm still with her
she was blonde and not stupid
for most the little miters getting
behind the wheel of a car was the road
to independence and freedom
louise mason was determined to drive no
matter how difficult it was for her just
physically to get behind the wheel and
do up her seat belt
[Applause]
my driving instructor had never
instructed a
disabled person let alone
somebody had gotten arms and legs
but the
tests we took
was exactly the same as everyone else
there was no difference
it came so natural because i've been
driving electric wheelchairs for
most of my life
and um
getting in a car was just a
bigger wheelchair really
my parents they were
the most practical people i think i've
ever met in my entire life
so when it came to learning how to drive
that was just practical that way you can
get around on your own you don't have to
depend on people to take care of you
don't have to worry about
you know taking a bus or using a cab and
it was really just about trying to
figure it out
anyway i just love driving
my favorite things in the world to do
most people don't consider the power of
my mind
and i my mind is a very powerful tool
and it it it interjects all kinds of
things into my system so that my feet
are literally
my hands so when it comes to driving
i take it really seriously i have high
exp why can't i can drive with one foot
on the wheel what is people's excuse
they've got both hands and their feet
and yet they drive like [ __ ]
this doesn't make any sense to me
in germany nico von glazzo knew from an
early age he had to choose a future
occupation that would not require the
use of his deformed arms
in midfield
i realized quite soon i never will be a
conductor
or a painter or a dancer
i can't sing
so i became a director because i'm you
know i can't do anything else
to pursue his dream nico went to
prestigious film schools and apprenticed
under the legendary german director
raynor verna fassbinder before making a
number of successful feature films but
there was one prized job he wanted badly
directing a big movie on thalidomide and
the head of german tv said no you can't
have the job
but you can make a documentary on
uh thalitomite and i said you know i you
know i
that was in [ __ ]
and i shouted at him i i used the f word
very loudly and very often
because i said i apply for the job you
know you pay well and not a f
documentary filmmaker who gets not paid
yeah
and that's so typical you know you give
the disabled guy the side job yeah
and then i went home and my wife said
what's the matter and i told her they
want me to do a film about thalitamite
and what do i know about thalidomide
yeah
and she looked at me and said
nico it's time to look the devil in this
[ __ ]
moni eisenberg was being raised by a
poor single mother after her father died
in a mountaineering accident when she
was nine by the time she was a teenager
moani had become an activist against
gruningthal if crunetile as a company
can act in a way they have in the case
of contagon there are really no
boundaries between right and wrong
[Music]
over the next 40 years money
participated in protests and hunger
strikes against the drug company
but there was also tragedy that occurred
regularly over the years that brought
moani to the gates of the grenanthal
plant this is a place where they spread
out all this poison in the world and
affected so many people and so many
families
and it's um let me always bit shiver in
the inside
because it's touching me too much
so i brought letters and candles here to
grunental anytime when i heard that
somebody of us survivors
indeed died
we need to remember all these people all
these
victims of grunenthal
and
just to remember that we are still here
what thalidomiders didn't know was that
the drug was still in circulation though
gruningthal had stopped producing the
drug thalidomide made an early comeback
in the mid 60s when other suppliers
began manufacturing it in india and some
south american countries where it had
become the drug of choice for treating
leprosy by 1972
and 1973 we're now 12 years after the
withdrawal of the drug
it was reported in use at 62
leprosy centers around the world
and was clearly being used on a massive
scale
one of the main countries using it for
this application had been brazil
and by 2003 they were they were probably
in the order of a thousand thalidomide
babies had been born in brazil across
that period
and the ability to control
this euphoric addictive
drug that's widely available in latin
america is impossible
so at this point i do want to introduce
my good buddy he's become a good buddy
timmy
alvin law found himself in the public
limelight when he became his province's
spokesman for a handicapped children
i can be
what i think
[Music]
over the years alvin would make
appearances on telethons across the
country i think i can
[Music]
i'm not better than other handicapped
people
because i'm not a handicapped person
that's where people get it wrong right
they look at alvin law and they think
god it's tremendous how he can do things
with his feet
well i suppose if you look at your feet
it's tremendous but these are my feet
these are my hands too and i have been
doing it forever these are not
tremendous feet these are the only thing
that i've got
so when i pick up a cup and i have a
drink you know
wow what a thrill that's not what it is
it's how i do things
[Music]
[Applause]
life wasn't so kind for another
thalidomide poster child louise mason
continued to endure bullying from other
kids at her institution for the handicap
but one day when she was 13 she was
raped by another student
louise went to a nurse for help
i was shaking i was tearful
and
they took my underwear off
and saw blood
and i tried to explain to them what had
happened they did nothing
they did nothing at all
louise endured five more years of fear
and loneliness before finally leaving
the institution then like any 18 year
old louise immediately started to enjoy
the freedom and joys of college life
i went to parties just for the sheer
hell of going to the parties i'd be
absolutely clean crackered
but i'd still go
because
it was something that i shouldn't have
done
or wasn't allowed to do
i went to the pub
regularly
drunk not severe regularly i got into
trouble there you weren't supposed to
have boys in your room i did and
but i made it say i got to the vice
president of the student union
and got well respected
unlike louise mason who rarely saw her
mother during childhood jan schulten
formed a close bond with his mother from
birth and her unwavering support and
encouragement were critical in his
career decision she never lost hope she
she said you you everything you want to
achieve in your life you're going to
achieve it i have absolutely no doubt
and when i when i
turned up with the with the idea that
um that i wanted to be a doctor
everybody told me you should not it's
not a very good idea you cannot do that
you will have severe problems
she said son do your own thing
if that's what you want to do
you're going to manage
jan is now an emergency room doctor in
switzerland i don't consider my
condition as a major issue i mean
i'm not a thalidomide in first spot i'm
first but i'm a man i'm trying to be a
good doctor i'm trying to be a good
husband i'm a father i'm a lover
and i have short arms and that's it and
and if people have problems
um
accepting me or
i have problems to interact with me
because i have short arms it's their
problem it's not mine
in canada most of the country's
thalidomiders hadn't received a penny of
compensation for their injuries for 25
years the canadian government had failed
to live up to its promises to look after
the victims of this drug
so the war amputees of canada brought
them to ottawa in 1987.
unlike their german and english
counterparts the canadian victims had
spent 25 years separate and apart from
each other it's kind of interesting
finally after 25 years to sit down
with a group of people you're kind of
related to and start to find out exactly
what everybody else is doing
the thalidomide victims association of
canada was formed with paul murphy being
elected vice president and alvin law
recording secretary
after years of waiting suffering and
fighting for compensation canadian
victims of thalidomide are finally
getting the help they need from the
federal government yesterday the health
minister said survivors of the drug will
receive lifelong pensions individuals
can now start feeling comfortable about
their future
they know they have
an amount of money coming in every year
that can support them and help them
hey i don't know what your lives are
like sometimes life can really be rough
on people i understand that i get it
i've been in real life
alvin law is a motivational speaker
who's influenced audiences in north
america and australia with his message
of hope especially to more than two
million youngsters who've heard his talk
speaking is the best thing that i could
have ever decided to do
you're helping kids
and they need to have somebody come in
and tell them that it's going to be okay
but i get such tremendous joy out of
doing it
there is nothing in my life that makes
me happier than speaking to kids
nothing and the next time you're ready
to give up or quit or pack it in
well if it helps even a little bit
remember the goofy looking guy that
played the drums with his feet
but remember the words i live by every
day
there's no such word
as can't
thanks man we'll see you again
how many people can say that they can go
out and speak to a group for an hour
and have them actually you can see the
change
you can see the reflection
you can see the thought that's going on
in their mind as to what they've just
experienced
alvin travels over a hundred thousand
miles a year on his own but after 30
years on the road his body is starting
to wear out it takes its toll you know
carrying that stuff around i mean you
know my body uh may not last as long as
normal bodies do because of what i'm
putting it through i mean as much as i
make this look easy
i'm still putting my body through a lot
of stuff
just the pain in my back from carrying
my luggage and scar tissue in my
shoulder from carrying a briefcase for
35 years you know there's not really a
shoulder here so what i'm carrying it
with
i shouldn't be doing this i should have
like a sherpa or something
okay how does a guy without arms
function on the road all by himself
carrying my own luggage with straps i
check into hotels all on my own i i rent
cars all right my keys there you go
thank you boss right on my toes thank
you all right now why do i rent cars
it's just how i prefer to function i
don't do cabs cause strangely they don't
stop when you go
i'm still tromping around going to
airports checking into hotels eating bad
food driving everywhere in the middle of
nowhere getting involved in blizzards
and swearing at my wife for putting me
out yet in another life and death
situation and not thinking i'm getting
paid enough
see what i mean i can get on a rant but
at the end of the day she also says this
line this is a wonderful line
honey if you're tired of traveling i'm
sure there's a cubicle with your name
written on it in a windowless office
somewhere in the middle of nowhere for a
mundane job that you'd hate in five
minutes
and then it goes away
[Music]
in germany nico von glazzo had to
overcome his lifetime aversion to other
thalidomiders when he decided to make a
documentary in which he and 11 other
victims would pose nude for a calendar
first i went to a disability school
and from that moment on i wanted to have
nothing to do with
the little miters anymore
and then because i made this film
nobody's perfect
i was kind of forced to meet them again
and i hated to make this film
why
i didn't want to look at myself
[Music]
nobody's perfect changed everything very
good
it changed how i look at myself
it changed
the movement of thalidomiders
completely because the first time not
lawyers not someone else not doctors
were fighting for us
really big time we were fighting
i think for me
for us as the lender mighters but also
for the public
something changed
the energy changed
nico von glazzo paladio
nobody's perfect
[Music]
in 2008 nico received the german
equivalent of an oscar for his
documentary on thalidomide
that is
[Music]
but i still didn't get the money
in college eileen cronin fell in love
with andy a graduate student in
economics i was in love
very definitely at first sight
um
although
i already had a boyfriend you know i
immediately was drawn to her
you know her vivaciousness and
intelligence and
her wit
we moved in together
[Music]
and
we got pregnant very quickly
very quickly
i was wracked with worry
all my life
about having a child because i didn't
know for sure that my mother had taken
thalidomide
i was kind of panicked
um it started to settle in oh my god i'm
gonna have a baby i don't even know if i
can have a baby um i don't know if the
baby's gonna have legs or not have legs
or something else but also
literally i did not know how i was gonna
carry a baby in my body
and so
um they did the ultrasound
the ultrasound technician
zoomed in right away
found
foot
one foot
blew it up
took a picture and wrote foot
and then other foot hands fingers
and
i was crying and all the interns started
clapping
we knew that she would be okay
anya
and eileen are best friends
it's it's not
hard to understand why anya took up to
be
a ballet dancer because that's something
her mother wanted to be
when she was very young
[Music]
his first wife sandy became pregnant
alvin law was terrified about what the
future held
when i saw him come out of there with
two arms and
two hands and five little fingers on
each hand
i didn't care what brand he was at all i
don't care if it was a she or a he or
any it didn't matter
and it was just the most tremendous
feeling it was my son
you want to do it
again we go
[Music]
can you throw it back i worried a lot
about how i was going to play ball with
him and
i was going to maybe how could i teach
him no to golf and teach him to play
frisbee and teach them to throw up you
know i mean all those things that you
want to have a kid of yours do
[Music]
you don't have to have arms to be a
father
you don't need arms to love them
you don't need arms to be there
you don't need arms to listen
you don't need arms to be a father at
all
and unfortunately too many fathers that
have arms don't realize that
[Music]
never forget that and that's true
you just have to be there for him
that surprised me
the tears i don't know i'm not sad i'm
just
wow
he's big now
he was little then
yeah well i miss that little boy
sometimes but that's not how life works
right
he's a normal regular person he's uh
he's got the same regular personality
there's nothing
really wrong about it and you just have
to
just have to know him and you can't just
judge him by the way he looks
what he brings and what he gives is
much more so
than anything arms could bring you know
he
he gives a
great you know fatherly advice and he's
a great role model he's a great person
[Music]
and that's all you can ask
my disability
is not the most important thing whatever
happened to me
my children are the most important thing
whatever happened to me
something lovely
was the most important in my life not
something you know which went wrong i
don't think i ever actually sort of
consciously realized there wasn't
a moment or
a time where i consciously thought oh my
dad is disabled
oh
and i never really had any
issue with it for them it was the same
like for kiki or also for me it you know
when
when you are with me longer than you
know a few hours you just forget there
isn't much he can't do with me so
apart from maybe playing rugby
there isn't much you i can't do with him
like i couldn't couldn't do it otherwise
he's
a really good father and
he's very
a
big character
to say the least
it's good to be rich
yeah i work on it i'm getting rich by
the minute
more and more
why not
it's nice you know just bought myself a
castle
nico's castle is a 15th century home in
tuscany with 108 rooms including 18
bedrooms i'm very good with money
i mean i invested the right moment into
apple
and i went out at the right moment
nico uses a lot of his money to finance
charities in asia including an orphanage
in the philippines and a film school in
tibet
so rich people have the tendency
to are
stingy bastards
and i don't want to be one of them
louise mason had been a single mother
for 10 years when she received a
christmas card from an old boyfriend i'd
heard that louise hadn't been very well
and sent her a christmas card and come
down and said hello and i think the
spark reignited is the best way to
describe it
he
kissed me goodbye
and
butterflies were
i was sort of floating on
on a cloud
and he told his wife that he was leaving
she helped him pack the car
and then he moved down here
we've been together since
that was it
a little more that have an understanding
with each other
it's really weird you know louise can
nod at something and you guys wouldn't
know
what i'm talking you know what she's on
about but i know straight away what
she's pointing at you know just a nod of
the head or or or
a mannerism
you you pick up you know
the little murders you just pick up on
each other it says oh we've got a sixth
sense you know it's really really
fascinating how we
communicate with each other without even
talking
so we and i think we i think we were
made for each other to be honest yeah
and i remember thinking 28 years old
divorced got a kid losing my hair
gaining a gut have no arms what a
package
and then i got to thinking you know i've
got to change this
that's how alvin introduced himself to
his future wife darlene who was sitting
in the audience one day that conference
was the first time i heard him speak and
it actually believed or not sounds corny
but it was a life-changing event for me
i was in the process of
[Music]
considering making a final decision
about a rather unhappy marriage
i thought yeah he's right
life is too short i have to
make decisions for myself
i mean anybody that sees her for the
first time can't miss that smile and
just absolutely melt and i melted
i have friends who tell me that i smiled
more the day of my wedding than they've
ever seen me smile in my entire life and
it was permanently glued there for days
that was the beginning of the joy
it ended in that ring going on that
finger and it's still there today
ah you can't even describe it
it's like all these years of angst and
frustration just melted away in five
minutes
you still love him
i do it's kind of he's kind of gross on
you
you know life is never she's past her
best before date so she's got no choice
he's got to stick with me now there's no
option
[Music]
yeah i don't stop traffic anymore
no you know we
had our ups and our downs and we've had
some
highs and some a lot of
lows just like anybody else but it just
keeps getting better i know it sounds
cliche but
it's getting easier and better and
more fun there's a lot of credit that i
get for doing this
but i didn't just do this you know i had
my parents first
i had my teachers second
and then i had her
and those three
elements of my life have been give
they've really been what has supplied
the fuel for what drives me
[Music]
that squirrel waving at us
[Laughter]
i met paul on the internet
and uh i got a message from this
gentleman that
had a kind of cute picture so
we started emailing back and forth and
uh i came out to visit and moved
i fell in love
quickly
um i never noticed his disability
because it was paul that i was
interested in the person that he is and
his disability didn't matter to me i
always say he's the least disabled
person i know
the words i live by
are
there's always a solution
over
under around or through
in 1997 the thalidomide victims
association of canada faced an agonizing
choice a small american drug company
celgene wanted to bring thalidomide onto
the market as a treatment for leprosy
and cancer but needed the approval of
the federal drug administration in
washington
cell genes sought the support of
canadian victims for its application
if thalidomide can
change for the better the life of a
child with cancer
then let's produce it and let's give it
to these children and let's make their
lives better and if it's because of the
price that we had to pay
good then maybe we
can have some solace in knowing that it
wasn't all in vain
in july 1998 the u.s food and drug
administration licensed a
thalidomide-based drug but imposed the
tightest rules on its use for any drug
in history
officially celgene got fda approval for
thalidomide to treat lepers a minuscule
american market but the drug company
quickly began focusing on it as a
treatment for multiple myeloma a cancer
of the blood cells and got approval for
that use in 2006
today celgene leads the market for drug
treatment of multiple myeloma in north
america and many european union
countries selling its patented
thalidomide derivative for approximately
ten thousand dollars a month or three
hundred and thirty three dollars uphill
most recently in 2013 a major survey was
done
by a team of scientists reviewing
they reviewed over 70 studies
the conclusion was that any
benefit from thalidomide was very
marginal and the risks were very high
in australia grunenthal and diageo the
british company that bought distillers
were co-defendants in a multi-million
dollar class action suit centered on the
lynette row case melbourne woman lynette
rowe is suing the drugs manufacturer
gruningthal the company wanted the case
heard in germany where it's never
successfully been sued but the victorian
supreme court today dismissed that
application this was an application by
the company that made thalidomide the
worst drug in the history of medicine
to have an armless legless woman who has
no money and doesn't speak german if she
wishes to have her day in court have to
move to germany for the next five years
so we had diago and grunentel as our
defendants
grin and tale have this never give in
never admit a thing never concede fight
to the bitter end attitude distillers or
diageo took a much more
compassionate
sensible we'd say approach which was
once convinced of the strength of the
claim they settled with lynn grinnington
didn't pay a cent
we had to get up and face each day and
every day and cope
with the incredible damage the grunts
horde dropped
to lynn and our family
the settlement amount was a
multi-billion dollar sum
it was a sum sufficient to provide lynn
with first class care for the rest of
her life it really um has dramatically
transformed the rose lives
grunenthal refused to pay a cent of the
multi-million dollar settlement but two
months later held a press conference so
it could apologize to its victims for
the first time in 50 years
they apologized for some [ __ ] that
they didn't reach out to us or some
[ __ ] yeah
they never apologized
for the suffering they caused
and they didn't pay
for that you know for their wrong
there was no apology
apology comes from the heart
here
their apology came from their lawyers
our family couldn't have gone into
silent shock we had to get up and face
each day and every day and cope
with the incredible damage the groom's
hood dropped
to lean in our family
grinental is still a privately owned
company the wurtz family owns it today
just as it did in 1960.
uh it does not have shareholders
demanding
returns
the verts family's personal fortune has
been variously estimated at between two
and three billion euros
it would not drive that family into
penary or bankruptcy or poverty
to loosen the purse strings
and behave in a more generous fashion
towards survivors
i not only want the money i want the
revenge
i want the revenge you know they
they killed 5 000 children
yeah they made
another 5 000 children's life
miserable they made the life of 10 000
parents
awful yeah they are responsible
and they should pay for it
grunenthal no longer makes the linomide
and continues to deny most the little
miners outside germany any compensation
no survivors feel they have received an
acceptable apology
grindenthal refused to be interviewed
for this film
[Music]
today celgene continues to prosper from
the sale of its thalidomide-derived
drugs to treat multiple myeloma
prior to getting approval to bring its
version of the drug back onto the market
in 1998 the american drug company was
valued at 100 million dollars
today celgene's value has soared to a
hundred billion dollars
the original thalidomide drug is easy
and cheap to manufacture and continues
to be made and distributed by several
drug companies and governments to treat
leprosy
unfortunately it is mostly used in
countries that often do not enforce
rigorous controls and regulations
as a result thalidomide injured babies
are still being born
the little miters worldwide buoyed by
the success of the lynette roe case have
renewed efforts to fight for
compensation as they battle with the
continuing side effects of
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
you